So now, using that idea,
let's talk about coded photography.
Coded photography is really going to
get us into depths of kind to now
create different ways of
looking at the coded patterns.
The aperture in this instance,
how we can control it, and
how can we embed that information to
allow the camera to be able to see
additional bits of information that will
actually allow us to capture images.
Some of this should remind you of
what we did when we talked about
the light field camera.
Right?
In the light field camera,
we wanted to capture more information
than just the pixel information on
the sensor.
We wanted to capture more
information about the light field
that would allow us to
now generate new images.
The question now is,
can we actually do a lot of this, and
again we touched on it a little bit when
we talked about the light field cameras,
by controlling this, how we can actually
capture a novel image representation
that would allow us to do more
than a standard image would.
We've looked at how to do this
with projector camera systems for
lighting control.
So the coded exposure
basically kind of says,
is we want to be able to control light
that enters a camera in time by using
different types of exposure controls.
Coded aperture then, actually,
also impacts how much light goes in.
Remember aperture is the opening,
the size, we can control this.
This one we controlled the amount of
light goes in over time, this one we
controlled the amount of light goes
in by the size of the aperture.
Of course, we can control
the illumination, as we know about how
to do with among other things,
with controllable projectors.
We can also do a lot of control right
on the sensor itself of the camera.
An example of that,
that we've actually kind of seen also is
when we talked about the camera itself.
We looked at the bare sensor, which
was actually doing coded information.
Remember, the bare sensor,
basically, was coding how RGB was
captured at the sensor and then allowed
you to read it off with that code itself
helping us figuring out how to get
the right color at the pixel level.
So coded photography is basically the
concept, now how can we actually learn
more about how we can code these things
it-selves and put them on the image
representation that would allow us
to showcase newer forms of images.
What are these examples or
what we mean about that in a bit